hi guys hi everyone thanks a lot Pi data
Global for uh receiving me uh I just got
the bad news about the Portugal match so
I'm a bit shook still but I'll try to
make the best talk possible
um so yeah my talk is called mlops for
the rest of us a Poor Man's Guide uh to
putting machine learning models into
production
so uh first of all who the hell am I
what am I doing here my name is do arts
uh it's a Portuguese name I'm a machine
learning software engineer also a
contractor I'm originally from Lisbon
but I'm based in in Copenhagen Denmark
in the past I worked in strategy product
management new Ventures management
consulting so
um kind of a lot of different positions
um now I just I write code and try to
solve problems end to end
and the final thing about me is that I
like running a lot I run like three
marathons every year I'm not sure if
that's gonna last a long time but uh
we're here for that and and yeah I just
wanted to also man a shout out to Pi
data Copenhagen Meetup which is here in
Copenhagen which is also an awesome
Meetup that I host and I go to almost
all the time
all right so let's see let's let's get
to it so this this is a talk about
helping small teams cut through the the
thing
um and there's a couple of talkies I'm
going to talk about today first of all
LinkedIn how you're probably not like
them
um we're also going to talk a little bit
about cutting through the mlops hype uh
how to deliver models in production
that's going to be the core of the talk
and it's a lot about unsexy ml uh kind
of boring ml like some people call it
um and of course in this talk there's a
lot of opinions uh so many opinions this
is all from my experience uh so I only
know what I've seen uh so there's kind
of a lot of these things you can think
it's wrong doesn't apply to you if
there's any problems in that there's my
website there's my Twitter reach out to
me let's have a productive discussion
about it and so yeah Just Grains at Salt
remember to take a lot of them
so first of all LinkedIn
and I'm actually going to tell a little
bit of a story here I remember once I
was working on a recommendation system
and I was super excited like
recommendation systems that's all the
hype I'm super excited about getting
started and just delivering this
recommendation system to my client like
it's going to be great and I saw that
there's one Fang one one of these big
large Tech fan companies giving a talk
about how the hell do we build
recommendation systems and I was super
excited I'm like okay I'm gonna go to
their workshop learn all there is to
learn about recommendation systems and
I'm going to be the best ever and gonna
kill this recommendation system and and
make the the life great for my user
and unfortunately like 10 10 minutes
into this Workshop I was not
understanding a single thing there was
this machine learning engineer coming in
talking about things I've never heard
about and so I was kind of like okay I
don't know anything that's going on I
don't know how I'm gonna the hell I'm
gonna do this I don't know exactly what
I can do I'm clearly not an expert in
recommendation systems I'm Thrive and in
the end I still ended up delivering that
recommendation system so my point is uh
you're not LinkedIn you're not Facebook
you're not Apple uh you're probably not
Amazon and the caveat here is maybe some
of you are but you kind of get my points
uh this is a talk about those of you who
are not
and the point here is that they have
probably 600 machine learning Engineers
I actually Google this for one of these
companies and they have more than 600
machine learning Engineers they have
dedicated teams for everything you might
think of they pretty much own the public
Cloud they don't use the public Cloud
they own the public Cloud they have
research teams looking at the edge of
research and development of machine
learning they even sometimes have a
machine learning platform team who just
makes their their goal to make a
platform so everyone can use and things
like that and then there's you or or at
least me which normally I work in teams
of like four people maybe seven people
and then dedicated teams
um it's basically me uh I I don't always
have a data engineering team and
whatever other specialized teams kind of
helping me out developing models and
delivering models and I don't own the
cloud I'm trying to keep costs down
while I'm using the clouds and it's not
that much about research as is it's more
about delivering value
and it's about delivering that value
fast and and yeah ml platform team lull
like I wish I had one I don't uh maybe
I'm building one as we're talking about
it but still
um all right so that's the first part
about about those companies and how
you're not them uh now let's talk a
little bit about machine learning
operations
so for me machine learning operations is
not about adopting tools it's about
delivering value we've seen this Gold
Rush age of a machine learning
operations uh here to the right there's
an image of the number of machine
learning operations tools and how
they've just Rose from 28 2008 to 29 to
2020 so you have more than 300 machine
learning tools for all types of
specialized things like Hardware
modeling and training serving like we
have a lot of tools and there's a lot of
fear of missing out like fomo right I
mean should I should be using some of
these tools and there's a lot of spam
emails going around of people trying to
use certain tools and so there's a lot
of this focus on the tools but the
reality is that only 22 percent of
companies have put machine learning
models into production and so the real
problem that I see is the problem of
providing value it's not so much about
the tooling but it's much about the
value
um
and one thing that always happens to me
is that people come and they're like
okay can we make this model in a couple
of weeks
and if I apply the machine learning
operations mindset straight away I think
this
okay that's a lot of things we have a
data pipeline a machine learning
pipeline a software code pipeline we
have the monitoring and the logging we
have the model Decay trigger we have the
feedback the data versioning the
profiling the hyper parameter tuning you
know what I'm getting at right it's a
lot of different things so it's it's a
little bit unrealistic that you can
develop all of this uh in two weeks I
mean it's it's it's it's it's a bit
unrealistic
so how do exactly how do I uh and so my
experience how do I think small teams
can solve small scale or reasonable
scale machine learning problems
so we have six sections uh people data
start small production monitoring and
machine learning platform and let's talk
a little bit about the people aspect of
this first
so machine learning operations we've
said this it doesn't really start with
the tools it starts with the people
will come up to you and they'll be like
we need an ml model and this is very
similar to the sentence we need Faster
Horses
and when people really need one of those
cars instead of Faster Horses and at the
end of the day you are the specialist
the machine learning engineer or the
data scientist so be skeptical if you
can when someone is asking you for a
machine learning model because there
might be a possibility
that they don't want a machine learning
model they want a heuristic solution or
a software solution so you as the
specialist can try to ensure that they
really the machine learning model is the
solution to the problem
a lot of times I try to think less of
giving Solutions
and think more of giving a partnership
to whoever I'm developing a a model or
or solving a problem for and there's a
great book by a great blogger that I
like called Derek sivers calls called
hell yeah or no it's a lot about a lot
of about a lot of different things but
it also talks a lot a little bit about
this notion of saying no which I think
is a super important notion especially
when you're dealing with clients or high
pressure projects
and I also
always give the advice of don't build in
the basement
a lot of us machine learning Engineers
or let's say nerds in general have this
idea that I'm gonna build this model I'm
gonna go into the basement or into my
room for three weeks I'm gonna talk to
anyone else I'm just gonna do my work
and then I'm gonna come out three weeks
later and you probably have a problem
and probably something didn't really
quite work and your client or your team
or your manager is going to be super
surprised what the hell it didn't work
and that's because
there's a great value in communicating
regularly with whatever problem you're
solving and especially in machine
learning operations where these are
super tough problems to solve you need
to keep
your team or your clients continuously
in the loop hey every day every two days
here's what happened here's the
difficulties I'm facing here's what I
think we can do to solve them and in the
end of those three weeks nobody will be
surprised they'll be exactly on the same
boat as you and it will make a lot of
sense so my advice is if you can have
some sort of control over how you're
going to build that this thing and how
you're going to kind of project manage
this yeah don't build in the basement
all right
so let's talk a little bit about data
so data is super tough right like you if
you're a small team if you're not a fan
you probably don't have the data
uh you gotta go ahead and you have to go
and label that data which is a tedious
process I'm sure there's the machine
learning operations tool out there
somewhere for that and people always
talk about this thing about continuous
learning right but they forget that the
only problems that you can apply
continuous learning are problems where
you have natural labels uh not all
problems and you probably have a very
small number of labels
and this is tough right but but don't
despair there's a lot of ways to tackle
these problems like if you don't have
the data scrape it annotate it
um
if you have a label something things
like embeddings PCA similarities there's
a great uh a great project by Vincent
wormerdam on the bottom left there
um and also for the continuous let me
make sure you capture feedback really
early for your model and if you have a
small number of labels zero shots or
embeddings or fine tuning are great
techniques to apply especially in NLP
and this is one of uh the books I've
read this year that I really enjoyed
it's it's uh natural language processing
with Transformers by by O'Reilly and by
Louis to install and it shows these two
concepts that I really enjoy the first
one to the left is this nearest enabled
neighbor notion that you have a bunch of
data points and if you have a new data
point you can just look at its nearest
neighbors and you'll probably inferior
good enough or reasonable enough label
for that point and it pre-trained
embeddings are a great technique to use
for that
on the right side there's there was a
test that was that in this book of doing
applying something leaks like fine
tuning embedding knife bass zero shots
and how many training samples you had
and these guys with only 223 samples
using fine tuning they can achieve
already an F1 score of 70 or 0.7 which
is really good so you don't need that
many labels labeling 223 examples
doesn't take more than a day in my
opinion depending on the complexity of
the task but you get my point so there
are great ways of dealing with this data
issue
what about starting small
um
I normally in most of my projects I use
a combination of Pi Project
um and that's to the left that's Pi
Project of Tamil that's pep
62621 which allows you to Define your
project dependencies in a
packproject.tamil configuration file and
here you have the build system the
project and the dependencies that I use
and the optional Dev dependencies and
the thing about pip tools which is a
tool that was developed by jazz band one
of the the founder one of the core teams
at Django is you just write pip compile
and then your the requirement sticks in
the Pi Project are Tomo and pip tools
will automatically generate a
requirement txt file from
thatpackproject.com so you could just do
these two pip compile commands one for
the dev requirements and for the normal
requirements and just from those
specifications on your project you have
your requirements text done I know a lot
of people like poetry a lot of people
like Anaconda I don't I like lightweight
I like things that work on Docker
containers and they're kind of fast and
this has proven to be really really
robust for me so definitely advise you
to give that a shot
okay what about testing and machine
learning
um test enough to increase confidence
and ensure production does not break
that's kind of the main thing right so
most of these cases Pi test is fine and
here on the left you see an example of
me using a pi test
um uh Pi test test to test the
classifier and I use this
parametrization of tests you can see
like the Spy tester Mark parametrize and
text in an expected class
and I test the obvious like I hate this
should be the class pissed this school
should be the class chilled out but I
also want to touch the X cases what if
someone gives you an empty string what
if someone gives you a null what if
someone gives you an INT are you still
making predictions because you probably
shouldn't so touching those Edge casings
just enough to increase your confidence
and also knowing that your user is not
throwing anything at you and validating
user inputs it's super good to do and
it's extremely easy with with pi test
and parameterized tests there are some
other techniques but this one works fine
um
and then I use make files make makes
things simpler so I have this thing that
I in most of my projects I use make
files and what you're seeing on the
screen is basically a make file and it
has a couple of commands like install
install Dev build clean flake format Etc
and each one of these commands runs the
set of sub commands so make clean
removes all of like the cached files and
stuff like that and there's a neat trick
where you can add kind of a little
snippet to your make file and I've
included that URL on the bottom left
and whenever someone comes into your
project and writes make help it will get
automatically the comment for each one
of these commands and it's like a map to
all your project so Rights Make help
sees like on the bottom right all of
your options and then I went okay make
install make install Dev make test and
so it's a super easy solution for anyone
that comes into your project knows
instantly what they can do inside of
your project just because of this little
make file I think make files everything
from a lot of people think make faster I
think from the past they probably are a
thing from the past but hey so are
Terminals and they work perfectly fine
right so I I normally love using make
files and that's kind of the standard I
I've used and the people that work
really really like
all right I also use a lot of CI CD in
most of my machine learning projects so
cicd increases the confidence but also
enforces the standards that you want to
set in your project especially when
you're collaborating with other people
and to the left is an example of a CI CD
pipeline using GitHub actions like you
set the action up then we reuse those
make file those make commands that come
really handy like make installed have
make check make test and then on the
right is an example of that pipeline
right you have a first part of the
pipeline that just checks your code
builds the environment does the Leaning
and formatting because I don't want to
have discussions about single little
double quotes or or just one little
quote and does the unit test and then
once your code is checked then it builds
as a container it deploys it and also
tests the API and there's a little
integration test so check your code and
you deploy your code and this is super
easy to set up especially if you already
have all of the make commands kind of
set up it's it's super easy to set up
and I definitely advise you to use
something like cicd for for your
projects
all right
what about production
um
so I normally like delivering
containerized models leveraging the
public cloud
normally that involves using something
like Fast API and pedantic and Pi
identic is really great because uh Pi
identity allows you to Define
exactly what your API is going to
receive so on the top right I I see an
example of like features like sepal
width sepal length and pedanting ensures
that they are a float between zero and
one and whenever they are not afloat and
between zero and between one my API does
not accept that request
and so all of those edge cases and
things that can go wrong are
automatically eliminated by pi dancing
and fast API also provides automatic
documentation and validation of user
inputs and outputs of my API
I also normally dockerize most of my
apis machine learning apis and it has
been working great
and here on the right you also see an
example of that Docker file again we're
using that make file and now it's called
make production and then you have all
the installments and stuff and your
Docker file becomes really lightweight
and and and it works really nicely
and uh there's also a little bit that I
want to talk about about choosing the
right Cloud I think there's a lot of
science especially in machine learning
machine ml Ops and for data scientists
and machine learning Engineers of
knowing how to choose the right cloud
service
and and choosing the right cloud service
really matters
um you have essentially I'm sorry about
the lecture here but but you have
essentially three types of cloud
services you can use when you want to
deploy something right you have the es
which is like SSH into a VM ec2 Amazon
um you have the run my container like
the pop the platform is the survey the
pass which is something like Cloud run
or fargate or shooter containers and
then you have fast like functions as a
service which is Lambda Cloud functions
or Azure functions which is basically
yeah run my function
and I I've made some examples of some of
these types of services uh for each like
big public Cloud but they are all pretty
much the same honestly on the bottom
left there's a website called
comparecloud.in you go to that website
and you can see exactly what Lambda
functions means on Azure and and you'll
notice very quickly that they're all the
same
um and so you have these three types of
services right
and the difference between these is that
uh the public cloud provider or you
control different aspects of this for
example on EOS on sdg2vm you control
everything from the functions the app to
the runtime to the OS on functions as
the service in the other Spectrum all
the way to the right you only control
the function all the app the runtime and
the operating system are controlled by
the public cloud provider
there is no best cloud service
uh if you go to functions as a service
they're more scalable but you also have
less control uh you only play when you
pay when them they're on but sometimes
they're kind of underpowered and they
take time to like you know light on and
there's no Hardware right and that's
going to be a pain on the other side on
on uh like is and like VMS it's more
powerful you have more control but you
pay for the whole month and when you're
using a GPU that costs a lot and so it's
very powerful but also has like bad
things and so normally I tend to start
with functions as a service and then
start going into EOS the more complex
the project gets normally my sweet spot
is around pass like hey here's my
container run 50 of them if you need and
that's really helpful so normally that's
what I go for
and let's talk a little bit about
monitoring as well
essentially for me there are three types
of monitoring so I've drawn this sketch
and like here's my machine learning
application in this green box the first
monitoring you do is like logs and error
monitoring like something like open
Telemetry I just want to know if
something breaks in my code and so you
do that
what I also do in mostly my apis is that
I actually store all the inputs to the
API and the outputs of the API and I
store them in like bigquery or something
like that you see the little red box and
I just store them down and this is
really nice because it allows me to do
two types of monitoring the drift
monitoring looking at what I've
predicted in my training data set but
also for business purposes or for
reporting or whatever I want to know how
many cats I've predicted for the last
month and so I can also take those out
historical predictions and put them in a
dashboard like a metabase or I don't
know supercell or whatever you're using
so essentially the you have the drift
you have the logs the error monitoring
and then the business reporting those
are kind of the three aspects and it's
relatively easy to set up all of them as
some as long as you're like like saving
everything
basically
and so we can actually talk a little bit
about a little bit more about this I
want to also talk about the drift
monitoring aspect of it evidently it's
like an open source tool that I use and
it's super easy to set up on the same
kind of routes as your API and so
normally if I have a machine learning
API someone can go to slash routing and
it automatically shows a drift dashboard
on my website there's actually a a blog
post just about that I don't know if
it's the recommended way of approaching
things but you can send me an email and
and tell me what you think
okay what about ml platform well big
secret there is none there is not a
machine learning platform it is a cookie
cutter template I've come up with this
set of ideas and this set of Concepts
and things that I enjoy and have been
working for the past years and have
evolved over time it's a template that
evolves with my practices and what I've
learned and you have the GitHub
workflows the docker file all your
notebooks and requirements and your sort
code and when you just use the cookie
cutter and we apply them to different
projects and that cookie cutter evolves
I don't call that a machine learning
platform but it's a template that has
been you been working a lot of time
since a lot of different microservices
and apis and machine learning models
that I've built and it works incredibly
well
so uh I encourage you to use something
similar cookie cutter is a great project
if you don't know what it is it's
basically a repo template that asks you
some questions and then you can all get
started
and so yeah that's a little bit about a
little bit about my my platform let's
put it like that
um all right
um okay so what's what's the point in
the end that you're trying to make Duart
so my point is first of all you're not
LinkedIn embrace it that's good it means
that you can do a lot of different
things and I like when things are tough
so uh yeah enjoy it enjoy the freedom of
like putting five hats on
boring technology is good technology I
like tools and I believe as you should
use tools but you shouldn't use tools
for tools you should use tools when you
need something that you're not that that
really has a little lots of value so
just don't go straight into the tools
then mlops is about delivering value not
using tools
and so squeeze all the juice you can
possibly squeeze on the tools you have
especially in small projects where
things can change from day to night
um yeah so I hope that was helpful and
uh thank you very much uh let me know if
you have any questions
yeah thanks Duarte uh we have a
yeah we'll take a few questions
yeah so one of the question by
Diego
for your three types of monitoring any
thoughts on choosing the right database
great great question
um Thiago go with Json like go with the
most unstructured thing you can find
because your API will probably change
with the course of time and if you go to
like an SQL database you'll need to
adjust or do some migrations on that
database with time if you just store
Json like it will always be Json so
whatever field you add or remove can
change over time and they won't affect
your dashboards so I would normally go
for nosql but I mean I don't know how
much data you're handling so maybe it's
like undoable but yeah go for nosql for
sure